You have selected Microsoft's M as the computer's default voice.
Welcome, welcome to the podcast UFO.
Now, welcome your hosts for tonight's show.
Florian Will and Stefan Kitz.
Um, Stefan Kze. Enjoy! Und ja, es wird eine neue Folge für das Podcast UFO geben. Ob ihr wollt oder nicht. Mit Stefan Tietze und mir. Und dir, Florentin Will. Da haben wir nichts geändert. Es gab ja lange Diskussionen, sollen wir noch eine Folge machen, sollen wir noch eine raushauen oder sollen wir es belassen? Aber wir haben gesagt, nein, wir brauchen noch eine Folge. Zwei, neun, drei ist keine gute Zahl zum Aufhören, deswegen kommt jetzt hier eine neue Folge. Ihr müsst sie ja nicht anhören. Für meine weitere Lebensplanung, was wäre denn eine gute Zahl, um aufzuhören für dich? Tja, das ist natürlich die Frage. Ich glaube, ab einem gewissen Punkt müssen wir eh so ein bisschen Sprünge machen oder so, dass wir irgendwie so ein paar Folgen auslassen und die dann später nochmal füllen. So wie ich so meine Rechnungen immer mache, damit es sich so aussieht, als wäre es 2022 001 im fucking Dezember. Nein, deswegen finde ich immer so ein bisschen was. Ich fange immer bei 10.700 an. Und dann 10.701, 10.702 und so weiter.
Damit man einfach weiss, oh krass. Nein, deswegen erfinde ich immer so ein bisschen was. Ich fange immer bei 10.700 an.
Und dann 10.701, 10.702 und so weiter.
Damit man einfach weiss, oh krass, da kommt eine Menge rum bei diesem, ja was macht der eigentlich?
Dann schlecht, wenn du dem Finanzamt dann mitteilen willst, dass du ja gar nicht so viele Einnahmen hattest, ist dann doof, wenn du anfängst mit 10.701.
Aber meiner Erfahrung nach kann man im Finanzamt immer reden mit so, ach komm, wir wissen doch, wie das läuft, komm, immer so ein bisschen gegen Schienbein treten mit dem Fuss, so, komm, hey, hey, hey, hey, immer so gegen die Augen hauen, so, das erschrickt so ein bisschen, hey, oder dieses in den Schwitzkasten nehmen, dann dieses drüber rubbeln, mit den Handknöcheln, das fand ich immer so unangenehm, wenn es bei mir gemacht wurde, wenn es meine guten Kumpels gemacht haben und dann immer dieses auch in Bauchboxen, dieses, hey, na, wie geht's, altes Haus, hasse ich. Haarausfall. Ist die Konsequenz, ja. Wenn du da über so den Kopf rubbelst, das ist eigentlich so wirklich, der klassische Männlichkeitsbeweis ist, ich nehme die Haare weg. Das ist schon früher, auch in alten, antiken Kulturen hat man dem besiegten Gegner den Skalp abgeschnitten, die Haare abgeschnitten.
Das überträgt sich heute in Bulli-Kultur, indem man dem sogar den Kopf reibt und damit 20 Jahre später zum Haarausfall zwingt.
Und Schadensersatzforderungen sind dann natürlich erloschen, weil dieses Rubbeln das erlischt nach drei Jahren leider, das ist verjährt. Das wissen Bullis auch ganz genau, wie was verjährt. Ich glaube, Brennnessel verjährt nach drei Jahren und einmal in die Mülltonne stecken nach vier Jahren, aber in der Regel ist es zu spät danach. Ja genau, wahrscheinlich lachen die ja beim Gericht auch so etwas, die lachen einen dann eher aus, dass man da irgendwie Schadensersatzansprüche stellt. Und der Gericht sehr verspätigt in den Spind. Das kann passieren. Das ist die Strafe, also die Strafe, sie werden jetzt in den Springen gespielt, weil es handelt sich natürlich um einen Männlichkeitskampf, der gewonnen wurde. Und der Gewinner des Männlichkeitskampfes darf natürlich dem anderen die Haare ausreissen. Das ist so in dem Männlichkeitskodex vermerkt. Das war ja auch, glaube ich, so in der Hochzeit von Breakdance ja auch ein großes Problem, dass dieser sich auf dem Kopf Kreisel move, das habe ich mal tatsächlich mitbekommen, weil mein Bruder wollte Breakdancer werden. Ich sagte immer, so entstehen Wirbel. Das kann auch sein. Das ist das Problem, wenn du dich zu sehr in eine Richtung drehst. Ja. Das ist die wichtigste Regel bei Breakdance, ist für jede Rechtsdrehung musst du auch eine Linksdrehung reinmachen, sonst hast du am Ende Wirbel, sonst ist dein Kopf verwirbelt. Ich habe zu viele Wirbel, das sagt meine Frisörin, ich habe zu viele Wirbel und dann sage ich, ja, es liegt einfach an meiner Breakdance-Vergangenheit. Da war ich jung und unerfahren und wusste nicht, was ist. Es ist ein bisschen wie, man weiß nicht, wann man damit anfängt, was es für Konsequenzen hat, gesundheitlicher Natur. Nee, das weiss ich nicht. Es ist wie Rauchen. Breakdance ist wie Rauchen. Es gibt auch keine Langzeitstudien von Breakdance. Das Einzige, was der Friseur dir verschreibt, ist so, ich verschreibe ihn jetzt tausend linksdrehende Linksdreher, um ihn wieder rauszudrehen aus den Haaren. Das ist das Ding. Aber bei meinem Bruder war es dann so, ich glaube, daher kommt auch so ein bisschen diese Cap-Kultur. Diese Baseball-Breakdance-Cap-Kultur, dass man sagt, damit die Haare nicht ausger... Ich weiß gar nicht genau, was da passiert, die einfach verdreht werden zu so einer grossen Dreadlock vielleicht. Oder kriegen die so Locken oben. Das kann auch sein. Eine grosse Dreadlock nach oben. Ja, stimmt, das kann auch sein. Aber das ist ja der Bart-Simpson-Look, so eine grosse Dreadlock nach oben. So richtig, einfach nur eine nach oben. Ich muss ganz ehrlich gestehen, sorry, aber ich weiß nicht, wo bei den Simpsons Haare anfangen und Kopf aufhören. Nee, aber immer darauf achten, wenn die ins Meer gehen oder so, wenn die nass werden, dann hat man immer so ein bisschen eine Idee davon. Bei March weiß ich, wo die Haare anfangen, Korsblau. Ja. Bei Bart weiß ich das nicht. Nee, aber auch da achtet mal drauf, wenn sie ins Wasser gehen, dann hat man immer so ein bisschen eine Idee davon. Bei March weiß ich, wo die Haare anfangen, cause Blau. Bei Bart weiß ich das nicht. Aber auch da, achtet mal drauf, wenn sie ins Wasser gehen, dann hat man eine Chance, das zu sehen. Also als Comic-Affizionado habe ich da immer ein Auge drauf gehabt, weil ich genau wissen wollte, was ist das, wo ist die Kopfform? Wo sind die Haare? Wird aber auch teilweise ein bisschen mit geulgt, ist ja eine Gag-Parade da, dass teilweise auch die Skelette dann diese Form haben. Und ich glaube, das ist ja hier auch klar. Tobias ist der Name des Komponisten des Intros, der uns verzaubert hat mit Klängen und Akkorden, also Gleichklängen von verschiedenen Tönen, das hat er gemacht. Und damit danke an Tobias. Also er hat dann, muss man sagen, mit verschiedenen Wellenlängen gearbeitet, die unterschiedlicher kleinste gemeinsame Nenner. Je kleiner der gemeinsame Nenner der Wellenlängen, desto normaler, wohlklingender klingen jetzt erstmal so die Töne. Ja, das mag jetzt erstmal kompliziert klingen, für Tobias ist das normal. Das ist für den Alltag, aber für uns ist es kompliziert. Aber so eine Quinte hat, glaube ich, so zwei Drittel gemeinsame Wellenlängen. Tobias Gähnt jetzt natürlich. Tobias Gähnt! Trommelt gelangweilt mit den Händen auf den Tisch. Genau, trommelt mit gleichzeitigem drei- und viervierteltag polyrhythmisch, klopft er auf den Tisch und sagt, wann geht das jetzt weiter mit der Folge, wann kommt es in Gefilde, wo ich auch was lernen kann. Wir müssen mich enttäuschen, wir lernen heute nur die Basics mit dir, Tobias. Absolut, wir können dir nichts dabei bringen, Tobias, du bist entlassen. Du kannst heute früher nach Hause gehen, denn Tobias, du weisst alles, du weisst mehr als wir. Was heißt genau, Class is dismissed? Ich dachte immer, für mich hat es immer geklungen, als wäre er jetzt vorbei. Als wäre er, alle sind entlassen, aber das klingt mehr, aber es ist eher so ein, es ist einfach vorbei, aber das klingt so viel offizieller und grösser als es ist. Es klingt besser, es gibt viel besser englische Wörter, disbanded, to cease, to exist, sowas, in Deutsch halt nur aus. Klasse aus. Das war's. Das war's. Tschüss Sikowski. Ja, Ende gut, alles gut, sowas in der Richtung, alles hat ein Ende, nur die Wurst hat zwei, sowas, da muss man dann natürlich im Vokabelkasten ein bisschen in die Breite gehen, wenn man als Nicht-Deutschsprachiger das lernt. Viel Erfolg übrigens, wir haben viel, auch kriegen manchmal Nachrichten von Leuten, die sagen, wir haben Deutsch gelernt mit dem Podcast-UFO, herzlichen Glückwunsch dazu, viel, viel Spaß, wir hoffen, dass euer Vokabelschatz nicht irgendwie einseitig ist oder eine gewisse Unwucht hat in die Breakdance-Szene. Ja, genau, viel Spaß im Alltag auf jeden Fall mit eurem geballten Wissen, Duftkerzenwissen und Freizeitpark thematischem Wissen. Die Herren wurden nicht gescholten, also da habe ich eine richtige Schelte hinter mir mit den Duftkerzen. Die Idee gibt John, warum? Das ist Quatsch, mach das nicht, aber auch einige konstruktive Ideen, weil du hattest ja die Glocke ins Ring geworfen.
Die Käseglocke.
Zu sagen, es braucht eine Glocke, die die späteren Gerüche bedeckt.
Da hat jemand gesagt, man könnte ja auch dann nicht nur die Schichten machen, sondern auch Mantel machen.
Dass sozusagen der äusserste Mantel die innere Duft in Zaumen hält oder in einem Zaun.
Kann man Duft im Zaun halten oder wird der dann kondensiert nach oben, wie man das von Tschernobyl kennt, so nach oben gedrückt? Also erst mal die Idee war, um alle neuen Hörer, Hörerinnen reinzuholen. Aber hier ist es auch schon Folge fünf, wo wir diese mittlerweile komplett die Wand gefahrene Idee. Ich hatte nämlich mich zu Hause hingesetzt. Korrekt, also mein Experiment ist gescheitert zum Thema, inwiefern kann man die Geruchskaskade, inwiefern ist sie möglich? Erst Geruch A, dann Geruch B, bleibt Geruch A im Raume, kommt Geruch B als unerwünschter Cousin dazu und vermischt sich, oder kann man sagen, erst Geruch A, dann Geruch B, die Idee ist eine Schichtenduftkerze, die verschiedene Gerüche nacheinander abfeuert. So, und ich bin jetzt mal ein bisschen out of the box gedacht und dachte mir, komm, legen wir die Kerze erstmal zur Seite und gucken, was es nämlich noch gibt. Und es gibt ja, da bin ich auf Jahrtausende alten wütenden Kampfgestoßen, der existiert, zwischen den Duftkerzen-Affizionados und den Dufträucherstäbchen-Affizionados. Und ich dachte mir, okay, kann ich mit dem Räucherstäbchen-Aficionados. Und ich dachte mir, okay,
dann kann ich mir mal Räucherstäbchen.
Das habe ich mir sehr, sehr wertige Räucherstäbchen
gekauft und angezündet.
Und ehrlich gesagt glaube ich,
hier haben wir ein bisschen die Lösung.
Denn die riechen
für sich genommen sehr dezent
nur, unangezündet.
Nicht so wie Duftkästen, die gleich dann direkt mal,
wenn man nicht gleich eine Käseloche draufballert, das ganze Haus.
Moment, auch im Raum?
Auch im Raume.
Also wenn du einfach ein Räucherstäbchen einfach nur im Raum hast, dann duften die schon dezent?
Wie gesagt, nein, nur sehr dezent, wohingegen unangezündete Duftkerzen schon mal ordentlich...
Das ist deine Aussage, das konnte niemand bestätigen.
Doch, doch, doch, voll. Also deswegen gibt es ja diese Sachen und viele haben auch Deckel, viele Duftkerzen werden mit Deckel verkauft. Warum? Ja, aber das ja dann nicht die ganze Kerzen-Nummer, wenn die auch ohne angezündet zu werden, riechen würden. Dann heißt es einfach Geruchsblock. Es wird halt besser, es wird halt mehr, aber ich habe ja Duftkerzen zu Hause schon mal gehabt. Ja, aber dann kaufst du doch lieber fünf Duftkerzen zusammen und zündest keine an und hast sie den Rest seines Lebens. Aber gute, genau, die guten Duftkerzen.
Das ist doch eine Hektis, weiss doch die Duftkerzenindustrie.
Nein, aber die guten, von denen wir hier sprechen, die auch ohne Deckel duften und ohne angezündet, die sind ja teuer, da verkauft man sich keine Föhn, Flontien, da musst du nochmal von vorne anfangen im Foren, im Duftkerzenforum.
So, jedenfalls glaube ich, wir sind hier ein bisschen an der Lösung, kratzen wir bereits, weil Duftstäbchen waren super, denn die riechen nur sehr dezent, wenn du die dich anmachst und die haben eine sehr gute Brenndauer und zwar genau die, die wir brauchen. Plus, es ist auch weniger Material, brauchst du. Ich glaube, es ist generell einfacher, verschiedene Schichten reinzuballern, die Geschwindigkeit zu timen und so weiter. Aber wie sieht es mit der Flüchtigkeit aus? Wie Flüchtigkeit, genau. Ist der Geruch flüchtiger? Das Geile ist, du siehst ja den Geruch bei Räucherstäbchen, weil die rauchen. Das heißt, du siehst genau, wie der Geruch kommt. Und es ist total geil. Du kannst, wenn du den ausmachst, ist der weg. Der verfliegt da noch, fliegt der Rauch noch ein bisschen hoch und ist weg. Also du redest hier von viel kürzeren Zeitintervallen, weil es halt nicht so ein mächtiges Geschöpft ist. Das ist total geil. Und das hat auch natürlich das optische Runterbrennen ist auch sehr schick. Also irgendwie glaube ich, da ist was im Raum. Jetzt musst du mich noch mal kurz abholen, bitte. Einmal die Grundlagen. Ist jetzt peinlich, aber ich muss zugeben, mir fehlen die Grundlagen. Was ist denn jetzt olfaktorisch der Unterschied zwischen Geruchsrauch und dem Geruchsdampf einer Duftkerze.
Das ist mir jetzt auch peinlich, aber darauf habe ich jetzt nicht unbedingt die perfekte Antwort.
Ich würde sagen, es kommt, also ich habe lustigerweise den gleichen Geruch dann einmal als Duftkerze und einmal als Räucherstäbchen gekauft,
weil da bin ich ja auch dann komplett drin in der Marte.
Ein bisschen wie Ketchup mit Tomaten, oder? Also das ist dann auch albern, wenn du dann den gleichen Geruch mehrfach machst. Ja genau, es ist wie Äpfel mit geschnittenen Äpfeln zu vergleichen, also es ist ein bisschen weird jetzt, aber ich sag mal so, es hat beides funktioniert, der ist schneller im Raum verflossen, der Duftstäbchengeruch und war natürlich ein bisschen mehr mit vielleicht so ein bisschen so Röstaromen, Raucharomen gesegnet. Okay. Aber insgesamt gab es keinen großen Unterschied, außer dass man jetzt irgendwie am Rauch gesehen hat, wohin sich der Duft so verflüchtigt. Also du sagst, das Schichtenräucherstäbchen ist hier vielversprechender, man tunkt es dann nacheinander in verschiedene, ja gut, das müsste man natürlich dann gucken, wie die überhaupt hergestellt werden. Das Problem an Räucherstäbchen ist, dass sie halt so billig sind. Du kannst ja nicht ein Räucherstäbchen verkaufen für zehn Euro, wohingegen eine Duftkerze mit Special-Effekt für zehn Euro ist unmöglich. Ich finde auch, das geht auch beim Molcherstäbchen. Wenn die aufwendig hergestellt sind, wenn die auch was hermachen sollen und gut riechen, dann glaube ich, können wir die auch teurer verkaufen.
Und jetzt kommt ...
Und jetzt geht aber auch, wir machen die grosse Moviebox, weil es gibt ja dieses, was man bei sehr vielen Basic-Menschen sieht, ist ja so ein grosses Poster, wo man Filme, wo die grossen Klassiker der Filmgeschichte drauf sind und man kann die wegruppeln. Casablanca. Und Citizen Kane, die beiden, und der Rest ist ja erstmal egal. Pulp Fiction. Matrix zum Beispiel. Fight Club. Pirates of the Caribbean. 2001. 2002, die Fortsetzung. So, zum Beispiel. Ja, genau. Life of Pi. So die Sachen. Hast du da gerufst und dann kannst du die wegrubbeln, die du gesehen hast. Wenn man jetzt sagt, wir bringen die ultimative, die 50 wichtigsten Filme aller Zeiten als Duftkerzen heraus und bringen dann eine Schachtel raus und du kannst diese Filme gucken zu den jeweiligen Duftkerzen. 50 Filme, 50 Düfte, hier sind die 50 Klassiker, die du gesehen haben musst, in 4D nochmal. Viel Spaß. Ja, kannst du natürlich auch noch die klassische Actionfigur-Liebhaberei mit reinnehmen, dass du dann sagst, du verkaufst das Komplettset für Star Wars, wo du halt einen Luke Skywalker hast, der halt statt dem Lichtschwert dann das Räucherstäbchen in der Hand hat. Ein lames Räucherstäbchen in der Hand. Oder Charlie Chaplin mit so einem Regenschirm oder seinem Gehstock oder so. Und dann kannst du es damit reinsetzen, weil diese einzelnen Räuchstäbchen für mich sind immer noch ein bisschen, ich sag's,
windig. Das ist einfach ein bisschen
wenig, aber bleibt denn was
übrig vom Räucherstäbchen, wie so eine Wunderkerze,
dass du dann so ein Ratsch gar nichts?
Nee, die verschwinden, lösen sich in sich selber auf.
Gut, wenn natürlich was übrig bleiben würde,
dass man das dann so einsortieren kann,
so den Film habe ich gesehen, so wie das Wegrubbeln.
Nee, okay, gut.
Enttäuschend, vielleicht ein Film, den die wenigsten von euch noch sehen werden, ist Matrix Revolutions, Resurrections, den wir gesehen haben, in letzter Folge besprochen haben. Ein Film, der uns kalt erwischt hat, würde ich sagen, der uns getroffen hat, der uns durchgewirbelt hat einmal komplett, oben nach unten, unten nach oben. Und sehr verwirrender Film, selbst für uns Matrix-Kenner. Und wir haben uns die uns die Frage gestellt wie muss dieser Film wirken auf jemanden der noch nie einen Matrix-Film gesehen hat der sich nicht auskennt ein Film der von Referenzen von Nostalgie von Bezugnamen lebt wie sieht dieser Film selbst in sich eine Meta-Besprechung des eigenen Films ist und der Herstellung dessen genau wie muss dieser Film wirken auf jemanden deren, der keine Ahnung hat? Und da hat uns geschrieben, die... Und das finde ich ein ganz tolles Szenario. In der letzten Folge wollte Florentin gerne wissen, wie es denn sei, den neuesten Matrix-Film gesehen zu haben, ohne jemals die anderen gesehen zu haben. Als ich Ende Dezember in einem Sneak-Preview saß, also einer Filmvorführung, wo man im Vorhinein nicht weiß, welcher Film gezeigt wird. Genau, was aber auch schon viel darüber sagt, wie Matrix lief. Wobei, er weiss es nicht. Ja, ich glaube, alle Filme kommen auch mal als Sneak Preview, glaube ich. Bei meinen Theorien ist immer, man gibt denen ja das, was überbleibt. Weil die Tagesspecials im Restaurant sind ja auch immer die Sachen, die man jetzt mal so loswerden will. Aber grossartig, ohnehin als Sneak Preview einen vierten Teil zu zeigen, ist eh schon mal einfach eine Ansage. Boah, sie, ja. Wo du sagst, die Hälfte des Publikums vielleicht einfach keine Ahnung. Grossartig, ohnehin als Sneak-Preview einen vierten Teil zu zeigen, ist eh schon mal einfach eine Ansage, wo du sagst, die Hälfte des Publikums vielleicht einfach keine Ahnung. Aber grossartig. Und mich auf einen gemütlichen Weihnachtswimm freute, wurde meine Erwartung niedergeschmettert. Unerwartet kam das Warner Brothers Logo und gefühlt alle wussten Bescheid. Und alle? Oh Gott. Verzweifelt fragte ich meinen Freund, okay, irgendwas mit Pillen, was muss ich noch wissen? Again with the fucking boyfriend. Warum müsst ihr immer, das zieht sich wirklich durch jede Hörernachricht, dass ich mittlerweile auch nicht mehr weiß, ob es ein Running Gag ist oder nicht, dass sie betont, dass sie Boyfriend oder Girlfriend hat. Dass er in einer unfassbar glücklichen Beziehung lebt. Dass er in der besten Beziehung der Welt lebt. Also sie fragte ihren Freund, was muss ich noch wissen, er hatte darauf auch keine Worte. Cool, aber dass du diesen Part erwähnen musst. Ich muss sagen, dass ich trotz der vielen Referenzen wirklich gar nichts verstanden habe. Ich wusste, dass das dann wohl eine Referenz sein soll, aber mehr dann auch nicht. Trotzdem hat mir die Story gefallen, bis ich nach der Hälfte des Films endgültig nichts mehr verstanden habe. Die blaue Pille ist ein Medikament, mit dem der Programmierer nicht verrückt wird, aber... Essentielle Dinge wurden nicht mehr erklärt, weil es gibt drei Teile davor. Die blaue Pille ist ein Medikament, mit dem der Programmierer nicht verrückt wird, aber auf einmal ist sein Therapeuten Computer? Irgendwo dazwischen bin ich also kurz eingeschlafen. Von der komischen Unterwelt, in der das Liebespaar der Geschichte in Gelee schlief, will ich gar nicht erst anfangen, in Klammern Fragezeichen. Ich hoffe, euch konnte dies einen Einblick geben in die Vorstellung einer Person, die nur den letzten Teil gesehen hat. Zehn von zehn would not recommend. Viele liebe Grüße. Ja, vielen Dank an dich, finde ich großartig. Also das stimmt schon, dieses Gelee-Schläfer-Paar, die blauen Peen, das ist alles nicht zu verstehen, überhaupt nicht zu verstehen.
Unerwartet hingegen habe ich gestern mit meiner Mutter telefoniert, die mir erzählte, und das zu meiner Überraschung, dass sie in den Film gegangen sei. Weil ich letzte Woche davon erzählt habe, ihr, dass ich in dem Film war, und dann hat sie es wohl für eine gute Idee gehalten, auch mal wieder ins Kino zu gehen, und da hat sie auch Matrix angeschaut. Und zur Überraschung war meine erste Reaktion ein schallendes Gelächter, weil ich jetzt auch nicht weiss, ob sie die Filme geguckt hat, die ersten drei. Ich glaube, die hat sie jetzt den ersten geguckt. Kann man das bei Eltern voraussetzen? Ich weiß es gar nicht. Wahrscheinlich hat sie auch die anderen beiden mal kurz geguckt und so, aber und sie fand den toll. und ich weiss nicht genau warum aber sie fand ihn sehr gut gemacht. Und ihr Verdict war, dass sie jetzt der Meinung sei, man müsste aber jetzt auch keinen weiteren mehr machen, weil es ja jetzt sehr befriedigend geendet ist. Und ich glaube, wenn ich sie mal in Ruhe nochmal spreche, dann möchte ich mal fragen, warum sie das jetzt so ein befriedigendes Ende fand. Warum das so schlüssig und sinnvoll geendet ist. Warum es alle roten Fäden aufgegriffen hat und am Ende zu einem sehr befriedenigen Ende geführt hat. Diese Frage möchte ich immer stellen. Ich fände es so cool, wenn einfach eine dezidierte Antwort kommt. Na ja, Morpholz und einfach eine sehr gute Erklärung dafür kennen. Ich glaube auch, dass vielleicht einfach auch nur wir so dumm sind. Wir immer über Filme reden, wo man sagt, das versteht niemand und Tenet haben wir nicht verstanden, aber vielleicht sind wir einfach so dumm, dass für alle anderen das völlig normal ist. Na klar, wenn die Zeit rückwärts läuft, dann musst du hier in der Richtung atmen, dann brauchst du eine Maske und der hat das dann in der Zukunft schon gemacht gehabt. Und wir so, ach so, wir haben einfach nur keine Ahnung. Ich komme hauptsächlich für Popcorn. Jaja, aber das ist ja auch da, wie die Geld verdienen. Ich habe tatsächlich, weil es ja immer gemischt ist, Popcorn, und das ist von Kino zu Kino unterschiedlich, was die verstehen als gemischt, was eine Mischung. Für mich ist eine Mischung schon ein völliges Durchdringen aller Komponenten. Manche verstehen als Mischung auch eine Schichtung, also dass erst die erste Hälfte der Tüte salzig ist und dann süss obendrauf, was in meiner Welt gerade keine Mischung ist. Nee, eine Schichtung. Einfach Schichtung, so, es ist einfach zwei drauf. Und dann habe ich eigentlich den gesamten Kinofilm mentale Diagramme, wo die verschiedenen Komponenten gerade sind und wie ich es schaffen kann, die noch zu durchmischen, während ich sie esse. Weil du kannst ja nicht schütteln und mischen, weil das ist ja randvoll. Das heißt, du musst erst was abessen, dann neige ich's, dann arbeite ich mich sozusagen, dann habe ich die Tüte so, dass die Öffnung rechts liegt. Und dann arbeite ich mich oben entlang der Decke der Tüte, damit ich hinten rankomme, um dann von hinten nach vorne zu schichten. Und irgendwann merke ich, da läuft ein Film nebenbei, der habe ich überhaupt nicht mit mir. Dann kommt noch jemand rein und sagt, Entschuldigung, sitzen Sie auf Platz 17?
Das war mir sehr unangenehm,
weil ich in Matrix konnte mich auch nicht so richtig darauf konzentrieren,
das ist meine Ausrede, weil ich da vor
eine unangenehme Situation hatte mit den Sitznachbarn.
Weil da sassen Pärchen,
aber die sassen nicht auf den richtigen
Sitzen, weshalb
ich mich direkt hätte neben
die setzen müssen, aber wegen Corona
wird ja immer einen Platz freigelassen gerade.
Und das fand
Vielen Dank. sitzen, weshalb ich mich direkt hätte neben die setzen müssen, aber wegen Corona wird der immer einen Platz freigelassen gerade. Und das fand ich nicht so geil, dass die dann direkt neben mir saßen, da habe ich gesagt, ich glaube, das ist auf dem falschen Platz, weil es auch so ein Randplatz war, wo ich dann war. Und dann mussten die und die, und er hat ganz cool reagiert und gesagt, ja klar, machen wir. Und die Freundin war so genervt von mir, dass ich darauf bestehe, dass zwischen uns ein Platz frei ist, dass ich nicht ganz genau, wir sind nicht im Guten auseinandergegangen. Ja. Und dann war ich die ganze Zeit, war ich peinlich berührt und so. Ich habe ein Geheimkino gefunden. Ah ja. Ich habe ja letzte Woche gesagt, groß raus posaunt, ich würde nie wieder in Kinos gehen, habe aber meinen Eid direkt gebrochen, sofort. Für welchen Film? Für Kingsman The Beginning. Okay. Schön, dass du meine Tipps ignorierst für Kingsman. Einfach angeguckt. Für Kingsman 9 hast du Annette nicht geguckt. Einfach in einem Anflug an Masochismus gesagt, das ist es jetzt. Und weil Daniel Brühl mitgespielt hat, ich bin ein Daniel-Brühl-Fan.
Deine Regel, du gehst nicht mehr ins Kino, hast du geboren für Kingsman? Ja, ich weiß, das war nicht so schlau. Naja, das war ganz gut. Und in einem Kino mit einem Special Feature, einem Feature, das, wenn man es nicht mal gesehen hat, einem nie als fehlend auffällt, Tische. An der Vorderseite, also an der Rücksitzen eines jeden Sitzreihe, ist so eine, wie in so einer kleinen Bar oder so eine kleine Reihe Tische, wo du denkst, ja klar, kannst du Sachen drauf abstellen, kannst du dein Getränk, Popcorn drauf abstellen. Und jetzt habe ich noch keinem Kino der Welt gesehen. Doch, im ganz alten Kinos, das kenne ich jetzt auch. Das ist ja fantastisch, ja, so grossartig.
Ich war mir im Urlaub an der Ostsee immer, das gibt es leider nicht mehr inzwischen, in einem Kino, was immer so, auch jeder hatte so eine kleine Lampe vor sich und die sind auch alle ausgegangen dann vor Licht und so. Ach so, die wurden alle, ah, okay. Ja, die wurden gelöscht, wurden die dann, aber man konnte vor sich halt immer ein Getränk stellen und so und dann gab es auch eine Bar im Kino. Ja, Vor- und Nachteile, aber schon geil, also man kann viel, also man, man, man, man, ich verstehe genau, was du meinst, jetzt vermisst man es in allen anderen Kinos natürlich. Ja, absolut, so, du bist es gewohnt, das so vor sich zu stellen, irgendjemand auch mal die Popcorn abzustellen, nicht in diesem Fressrausch zu verfallen, finde ich grossartig. Ja genau, was ich gar nicht brauche, wo man wieder einen Schritt zurückgehen könnte, sind diese Liegesessel, wo man dann so die Beine hochfahren kann. Ja und diese Pärchensexstühle, hast du da Erfahrung damit gemacht? Ähm, nee. Wo du dann auch schon bei der Reservierung siehst, ah dieser Liebes, dieser Lusttempel da hinten ist belegt, wo du denkst, ganz weit weg reservieren, ganz weit von diesem Erotik-Zentrum. Oder direkt dahinter, auf gar keinen Fall davor. Aber auch nicht unbedingt dahinter. So, das ist einfach, du weißt, okay, da geht's rund, da wird einfach Liebe gemacht. Und damit will ich nichts zu tun haben, das ist euer Ding, aber ich will einfach nur schön Kingsman, ich will Ralph Fiennes, der nicht mehr so richtig Bock hat auf den nächsten Teil, den will ich sehen und nicht euch.
Ralph Fiennes hat auch keinen Bock mehr, also wir gucken uns mittlerweile Schauspieler an, bezahlen Geld dafür, die eigentlich keine Lust mehr haben. Ralph Fiennes hat schon noch Bock, und dafür respektiere ich ihn auch.
Anders als Keanu Reeves-Degg.
Es ist nicht die Keanu Reeves-Ding, aber einfach die beiden auch in einem Film und beide so Mittelbock einfach.
Mittlerweile habe ich, ich ziehe eine gewisse Befriedigung. Ich habe das Spielchen auch. Anders als Keanu Reeves-Degg. Keanu Reeves-Ding, aber einfach die beiden auch in einem Film und beide so Mittelbock einfach.
Mittlerweile habe ich, ich ziehe eine gewisse Befriedigung daraus, so ehrwürdige Schauspieler, die einfach wahrscheinlich viel Geld dafür bekommen, dass sie nochmal dabei sind, die dann aber keinen Bock haben. Irgendwie macht mir das auf eine Art Spaß, Leuten zuzuschauen, die irgendwie nicht so Bock haben. Das ist ja auch so dieses Ding mit Kellnern im Restaurant, wo die einen sagen, ich mag das total,
wenn die so, hallo, guten Tag und freundlich und nett und so,
aber andere genießen es auch, wenn die einfach so
so ein bisschen arbeiten und auch nicht unhilflich sind,
aber einfach so, ja, was wollen sie, okay,
weil das einfach so ein bisschen weniger Energie haben.
Und das mag ich auch bei manchen Schauspielern,
wo du einfach merkst, ja, das merkst, das macht der so nebenbei. Es ist komisch, aber irgendwie mag ich das. Finde ich das eine interessante Herangehensweise, dass da einfach so eine riesige Kamera aufgebaut wird, ein riesiges Set, Millionen an Special-Effects-Budget, alles auf diesen einen Menschen, Mr. Reeves, gerichtet, Make-up, Kaffee, Catering, hunderte Leute am Set und der hat einfach keinen Bock drauf.
Der hat einfach keinen Bock mehr, will nicht mehr.
Und der macht das so, oh wow, yeah, we should look into that. Okay, cut, alle gehen nach Hause. Und auch der Tonmann fährt nach Hause in der U-Bahn an dem Abend und denkt sich, all das jetzt dafür?
Ja, ich keine Ahnung, also man ist immer schwer zu beurteilen, natürlich. Ich weiß nicht genau, wie das passieren konnte. Wir werden es nicht wissen, wir werden es nie erfahren. Nee, weil das die ganze Zeit ja passiert. Bis wir die Regisseurin vielleicht eines Tages im Podcast haben, du hast ja deine Tentakel ausgesetzt, du bist ja tatsächlich tatsächlich auch jemand der viele leute kennt dann aber auch diese verbindungen oft nicht zu was bringen kann ich bin jemand der um sehr viele ecken sehr viele leute kennt wie jeder ich glaube du kennst einfach nur eine person die wahnsinnig viele leute ja dadurch kannst du sagen ich kenne über ecken ganz viele leute dabei kennst du nur eine person man Man muss die richtigen Personen kennen. Die richtige Person, eine einzige. Ja, ich nenne sie Multiplikatoren, die muss man natürlich kennen. Dann kann man das immer schön behaupten. Und es ist ja auch wichtig, in dem Podcast Name-Dropping zu betreiben und sich wichtig zu machen, indem man betont, wenn man alles um ein paar Ecke kennt. Um einige Ecken. Um eine Ecke kennt. Ich glaube, um einige Ecken kennt auch jeder jeden auf der Welt. Also du kannst sagen, ja, ich kenne auch um einige Ecken, kenne ich Ralph Fiennes. Ich sage mal, diese eine Serie, wo ich die ganze Zeit am Filmset war, diese eine einzige Serie hat da geholfen dafür. Ja. Weil ich glaube, wenn man eine Person an einem Filmset kennt, die vor allem an Filmsets arbeitet, die kennen dann halt alle coolen Leute. Ja, das stimmt. So, das ist, glaube ich, das ganze Geheimnis. Aber ich habe noch nicht meine Tentakel, meine vielen Tentakel ausgestreckt. Du hast auch noch nicht das Colorado-Drehbuch irgendwie mal einen von denen in die Tasche gesteckt oder so, dass ich dir geschickt habe. Ne, da habe ich schon ein bisschen, da habe ich alle all at Netflix, all at Disney.com, habe ich mal geschrieben. Mach das einfach mal, einfach mal vielleicht so Verteiler existieren. Ja, mach das mal nicht, weil die existieren, ja. Einfach mal so everybody at disneyplus.com. Einfach mal raushauen, euer Drehbuch, euer Limerick. Auf jeden Fall, ich glaube so, jeder at barn.de ist bestimmt ein Thing. Also ich glaube wirklich, dass es ein ... Jeder at barn.de? Nee, nicht jeder jetzt vielleicht, aber alle at barn.de. Everybody at barn.de. Versucht mal jeder, alle, Team, versucht das einfach mal. Und einfach Verteiler. Und dann irgendwie kommt so eine genervte Mail von der Human Resource Beauftragten, die sagt, Leute, wir müssen jetzt unseren Verteilernamen umstellen, weil irgend so ein Ulk-Podcast hat uns erwischt. Und wir nennen uns jetzt irgendwie in Frettchen at Bahn oder sowas. Irgendwas Witziges, was Süsses. Was ganz Süsses. Ja, ich war jetzt gezwungen, mir einen neuen Laptop zu kaufen, wenn mein Alltag kaputt gegangen ist. Was heißt kaputt gegangen? Also zerschellt? Also, es können zwei verschiedene Dinge sein an diesem Tag.
Also er ging plötzlich nicht mehr und es war jetzt zufälligerweise so, sagen wir mal, zehn Minuten, nachdem ein bisschen Flüssigkeit in Richtung des Laptops geflossen ist. Ja. Ja?
Ich habe den aber sofort hochgehoben und habe alles sauber gemacht und so, und ich konnte
jetzt nicht so viel Flüssigkeit ausmachen, die jetzt in den Laptop hineingekrochen war. Und was genau bringt hochheben? Naja, so abwegschütteln, die ganze Flüssigkeit rauszuschütteln. Ach so, okay, das ist ja immer so, wie er ist hochgehoben. Kennt man ja, erstmal weg von der Gefahrenzone. Ja, eigentlich ist Höhe immer gut, also auch so, wenn ich mich als Kind verletzt habe, hieß es immer Finger in die Luft oder so. Ja genau, Seitenstechen, Arm in die Höhe. Ich glaube die Höhe ist erst mal gesünder als die Tiefe. Ja genau, weil die Gefahr ist in der Tiefe. Genau, ausser nicht stabile Seitennagel. Außer man ist sehr gross, dass man dadurch den Laptop gegen die Decke schmeißt. Aber erst mal alles in die Luft. Erst mal alles in die Luft und dann geht es weiter erst mal. Also habe ich eine Höhe gestreckt und trocken gemacht. So, da war aber jetzt nicht so viel Flüssigkeit dran. Vielleicht ist er aber in die falschen Ecken gestoßen, wie dem auch sei. In der Nacht gab es ein Update, glaube ich, und der Laptop ist einfach ausgegangen plötzlich. Ich habe den wieder angemacht und er ging auch einwandfrei, ausser dass eine Meldung kam, dass essentielle Updates geladen werden müssen, damit der Laptop wieder gestartet werden kann. Und das ging halt wiederholt nicht. Ich fand diese sehr kritisch, wurden sie genannt, die kritischen Updates konnte ich nicht laden. Dann habe ich den Apple-Support angerufen und er hat gesagt, ja, das ist ein bekanntes Problem, aber man weiß nicht genau, woran es liegt. Aber es ist wohl ein bekanntes Problem, er es in seiner Datenbank sehen. Und ich musste währenddessen eh schon die ganze Zeit ein bisschen lachen, weil ich mir sicher war, dass natürlich das ein bekanntes Problem ist, weil es ja im Kern ist, Flüssigkeit wurde auf dem Laptop gegossen. Aber keiner meiner Vorgängerinnen hat das jemals gesagt. Wahrscheinlich, wenn alle gesagt haben, mir dieses merkwürdige Problem, ich kann mir das nicht erklären, wie das passiert ist. Und deswegen war es ein bekanntes Problem mit Fragezeichen der Ursache. Du hast nicht erwähnt, dass es diese zu dieser... Warum denn? Warum muss ich das erwähnen? Weil dann wäre es ja ein Hardware-Problem. Er hätte mal gesagt, wahrscheinlich ist das ein Software-Problem, kann aber auch ein Hardware-Problem sein. Und ich bin immer bei Hardware so zusammengezuckt, weil ich dachte, okay, das ist vielleicht dann doch mein Problem.
Ja.
Naja, Humor war auch kein grosses Ding bei ihm.
Also, dann habe ich versucht, zwei Gags zu machen.
Zum einen sollte ich dann die Shift-Taste gedrückt halten während des Anmachens, um im Gesicherheitenmodus den hochzufahren.
Man muss wirklich nur die Shift-Taste drücken und dann auf Andrücken und das war's.
Dann habe ich gesagt, ja, wir haben uns reingehackt. Habe ich gesagt, kein Lacher. Und dann am Ende haben alle gesagt, ja, das ist ein sehr seltenes Problem, das wundert mich jetzt auch und habe gesagt, ja, freut mich aber auch ein bisschen, dass sie ein seltenes Problem haben, wahrscheinlich sind alle ihre Probleme, die sie immer hören, mit Ausmachen und Wiederanmachen gelöst. Dann gab es eine lange Stille und dann hat gesagt, nee, also mein Job besteht ja hauptsächlich darin, dass man gemeinsam an der Ursache eines Problems löst. Und klar, probiert man erst mal die Dinge, die vielleicht, oh, ich dachte mir so, Jesus Christ, dann hat er mir seinen Job weg. Also die Ehe war keine Ebene. Zwischen uns? Oh nein. Naja, dann habe ich mein Backup gemacht und so weiter und habe es dann zum Apple Store gebracht und ja, da kam dann irgendwann nach ein paar Tagen die Mail zurück, dass ein Hardware-Problem, ein Platinen-Problem vorliegt. Ja. Und das wäre so teuer geworden. Können Sie sich das irgendwie erklären, dieses Platinenproblem? Weil wir haben jetzt Rückstände von Himbeersirup auf dieser Platine gefunden. Haben Sie irgendeine Ahnung? Kann ich mir nicht erklären. Ich habe aber auch so gefragt im Laden dann und dieses Platinenproblem von dem, der Sie ja geschrieben haben, woran lag das dann? Und er hat so gesehen in dem Gesicht von ihm, er weiß genau, dass es vielleicht das war, aber er hat dann nicht gesagt, er hat nur diese Trinkpantomime kurz. Genau. Hups. Huch. Hups. Ein kleines Trinkproblem. Ja, jedenfalls genau, muss ich mir dann einen neuen Laptop kaufen, weil die Reparatur wäre so teuer geworden, dass es keinen Sinn mehr gemacht hätte so richtig. Also es war schon ein grundlegendes Problem. Und jetzt hast du was gelernt, dass du besser mit deinen Besitztümern umgehst oder willst du weiterhin so fahrlässig Flüssigkeiten um dich werfen, wie du es normalerweise tust. Ich meine, ich erinnere an den Account Stefan Tietze Spills. Du hast ein Verschüttproblem, du hast ein Spillproblem, Verschüttflüssigkeiten nicht unter Kontrolle halten Problem, was ist da los? Erstmal ist ja nicht gesichert geklärt, dass es jetzt daran lag. Ich liess diese Update. Wie der Himbeersirup denn tatsächlich auf die Platine kam, ist noch nicht geklärt. Für mich ist das nicht nachhaltig geklärt, wie woran es lag. Von daher weiß ich jetzt nicht, ob ich das so problematisieren würde. Wenn du mich in diese Spillrichtung da jetzt schiebst, weiß ich nicht, brauche ich jetzt nicht. Und dann habe ich, weil ich wollte eh einen neuen Laptop auch langsamer haben. Na klar, natürlich. Jetzt, da dein Alter kaputt ist, wolltest du eh schon eigentlich, ja, also hatte ich ja eh schon geplant eigentlich.
Und dann, was mich ein bisschen stört, also natürlich, was crazy war, ich habe dann ja zwischendurch in diesem gesicherten Modus, konnte ich dann noch ein Backup machen und konnte mir alle Dateien, weil ich auf der Festplatte konnte ich mein Backup machen. Dann habe ich den neuen Laptop dann quasi als den alten gestartet und alle Dateien waren wieder da, wo sie waren, alle Ordner sind da, im Hintergrund Bild war noch das gleiche. Und selbst das YouTube-Video, was ich geschaut habe, war noch an der gleichen Stelle angehalten. Und das fand ich echt krass. Mein neuer Laptop wurde gestartet, und es war genau so, es waren noch die gleichen Programme offen, und das gleiche YouTube-Video war noch offen, und an der gleichen Stelle ging es wieder los. Und hattest du Flashbacks zu dem Verschütten-Moment? Ja. Also hatte das was mit dem Video zu tun, dass du kurz aufgeschreckt bist oder prusten musstest oder hatte das was mit dem Video zu tun und hast du dann direkt da nochmal gepustet und dann direkt den neuen kaputt gemacht? Und das Problem war jetzt, also weil man freut sich ja über neue Dinge, es gibt ja nichts Schöneres eigentlich als einen verregneten Sonntag damit zu verwenden, irgendwie ein Schönen auspacken, sondern so auspacken und so konfigurieren, weil du hast im Prinzip nichts zu tun, aber es fühlt sich so an, als macht man was Sinnvolles und es macht irgendwie so eine befriedigende Arbeit. Aber jetzt, und Apple macht's einem natürlich auch sehr einfach. Und wie gesagt, das Server ist ja sehr toll, das Video fängt an der gleichen Stelle an. Sowas hat aber den Nachteil, dass man irgendwie seine hässliche Ordnerstruktur ist jetzt wieder die gleiche. Diese ganzen komischen Sachen, die man nicht brauchte, noch vom Studium, sind immer noch drauf. Nee, deswegen mache ich so, wenn ich neues Gerät habe, fange ich wirklich bei null an. Ich übertrage kein Backup oder so, ich fange wirklich bei null an, ich mache das Backup auf eine Festplatte, irre viel Arbeit, leg es in ein Regal und ich fange wirklich bewusst bei null an. Und dann hast du diese herrliche eine Woche, wo alle Vorsätze greifen, wo du sagst, nein, mein Schreibtisch bleibt sauber. Alles, was ich auf den Schreibtisch lege, wird danach, nach der Verwendung sofort gelöscht oder in einen adäquaten Ordner verschoben. Und du machst das auch eine Woche, bis dann so das erste Funny-Pick da landet. Und du denkst, ah, das kann ich dann noch ...
Das merke ich mir mal.
Das bleibt dann noch eine Weile.
Wenn ich das verschiebe, würde ich es aus dem Auge, aus dem Sinn.
Genau, das wollte ich ja eh noch im Lars schicken, das brauche ich ja eh noch, das bleibt erst mal da, das brauche ich schnell abgreifbar.
Und langsam startet diese Anmüllung und Vermüllung wieder genau so, wie es beim Alten auch war.
Aber du hattest diese eine herrliche Woche, wo alles perfekt war und du wirklich sagst hast, nein, ich mache einen Ordner auf und hier und ich sortiere das nach Datum und alles und lege da alles rein, worüber ich sehr laut gelacht habe, leise gelacht habe, geschmunzelt habe, eher so ein Wow, das ist lustig, ohne dass ich wirklich gelacht habe, sondern nur gesagt habe, das ist lustig und habe das richtig abgeordnet, meine Funny Picks. Super. Aber es bricht leider einfach nach kurzer Zeit zusammen. Also Umzüge haben ja was Bereinigendes, Neuanfang, was Bereinigendes. Das ist total sinnvoll. Und Apple macht es natürlich irgendwie, wenn man sich das mal als Umzug vorstellt, wäre es halt so, also du hättest Fotos gemacht von der alten Wohnung und dann wird alles genauso eingeräumt, wie es dann war in der neuen Wohnung. Das geht nicht. Und das geht nicht so richtig.
Und aber so habe ich, ich habe jetzt dieses unreine Gefühl, ich nehme den gar nicht als neuen Laptop wahr, sondern irgendwie, es ist noch diese alte Seele in dem neuen Körper. Du musst auf null anfangen. Und mir gefällt das unrein. Du brauchst den ganzen Kram nicht. Du fängst bei null an und dann machst du noch, wenn du sagst, ah, ich brauche jetzt doch nochmal meinen alten Essay, den ich damals im Reliktarricht geschriebenit geschrieben habe. Das einzige, was ich gemacht habe, war, ich habe den Studiumordner, den es noch auf dem Desktop gab, warum auch immer, habe ich genommen und in den Mülleimer gezerrt. Weg damit, vier Jahre deines Lebens, weg. Ja, und das hat mir schon ein bisschen geholfen, so ein bisschen über diese anfängliche, ist genau so alles, wie es vorher war, nur mal hinwegzuhelfen.
Und ich habe davor auch gedacht, die Sachen, die auf meinem Desktop sind, die sind ja aus dem Grund, habe ich die ja abgelegt. Ich sage mal, warum soll ich die denn jetzt da löschen? Und naja, aber das ist so ein bisschen, Apple sollte so zwei Migrationsstufen, finde ich, haben. Also einmal die, klar, wir haben Time Machine, wir haben das Backup, aber wir machen so einen reinen Neuanfang, wo man vorher durchklicken muss mit so, was will man eigentlich haben. Diesen Ordner hast du seit 15 Jahren nicht benutzt. Willst du den wirklich noch mitnehmen? Nee, aber ist doch eine gute Möglichkeit. So Migration löscht alles, was ich nicht in den letzten drei Monaten angeklickt habe. Und da ist ja wirklich nichts dann Falsches gelöscht.
Und du hast es ja im Backup, du hast es ja irgendwo auf einer Festplatte rumloren.
Nee, aber ich merke das auch bei mir, kriecht das jetzt ein und ich habe jetzt schon wieder alles vollgemüllt mit irgendwelchen Sachen und dann, ja, es ist schwierig.
Es ist schwierig.
Naja, jetzt habe ich das neue Ding, es ist das gleiche Modell, es ist nur dicker geworden wieder, wo man sich auch wieder dran gewöhnen muss, weil es eine sehr, sehr kontaktive Entwicklung ist von einem neuen technischen Gerät, dass es wieder dicker wird und schwerer. Es wird wieder dicker. Aber ich muss sagen, ich habe auch meinen alten Laptop, muss ich noch verwenden, weil es ist tatsächlich das einzige Gerät, auf dem ich erfolgreich mit dem das Podcast-Ufo-E-Mail-Postfach eingeloggt bin.
Das ist auf keinem anderen Gerät möglich. Ja, kurz dazu, weil ich versuche seit 15 Jahren von Florentin das Passwort und Zugangstaten zu bekommen, damit ich auch darauf Zugriff hat, kriege ich das nicht mehr hin. Ich kriege es nicht mehr hin. Ich habe damals ein Passwort gewählt, das nicht mehr zu rekonstruieren ist und es gibt auch keine Möglichkeiten, das nochmal zurückzusetzen oder sonstiges. Es gibt dieses eine Gerät, das hat gerade noch diese winzige Verbindung mit dem Internet, in der Form, dass ich auf dieses E-Mail-Postfach zurückgreifen kann. Ich versuche, diesen Laptop am Leben zu halten, mit allen möglichen Sachen. Ich benutze ihn zu nichts anderem mehr, sondern versuche, diese ganz, ganz brüchige Verbindung aufrechtzuhalten, weil wenn die weg ist, dann haben wir nichts mehr verloren. Ist auch so ein alter Laptop, wo das Netzteil kaputt ist und die Batterie, das Akku aber auch kaputt ist und der muss so, das Netzteil hat einen Backelkontakt und es muss aber die ganze Zeit am Strom sein und wenn der ausgeht, kann es sein, dass man ausgelockt ist und sowas, das heißt, der ist die ganze Zeit am Strom. Mit so vier Büroklammern und irgendwie Gummibändern hingeballt. Und wenn jemand da drankommt, dann war es das. Und da sind alle eure Mails drauf. Also alles, was an zentrale podcast-uvo.fail geht, ist da auf diesem alten Relikt drauf, das auch kaum mehr entziffert werden kann. Also das muss jetzt schon über mehrere Rosetta-Steine hinweg entziffert werden, weil das alte Technologie ist. Man muss mit Gandalf nach Bruchthal gehen. Und wenn der Mond richtig steht, kann man diese Runen lesen. Und dann kann ich eure Nachrichten lesen, wie die wir heute zugesandt bekommen haben zu Matrix. Vielen, vielen Dank dafür, aber seid euch im Klaren, dass viele dieser Mails, die ihr schickt, wahrscheinlich im Äther des Internets verschwinden werden. Weil was ist denn das für ein fucking Passwort? Wir hatten immer ein Passwort. Du weißt es. Ich weiss das Passwort. Du weißt es. Wir hatten immer ein Passwort, das wir verwendet haben für WordPress und alles, und das haben wir immer benutzt, und das ist es halt nicht, sondern es ist irgendwie so ein Passwort, wo man in dem kurzen Moment gesagt hat, nee, ich mache ein anderes. Das ist die grösste menschliche Schwäche, die es gibt, plötzlich zu denken, man könne sich jetzt ein neues Passwort ausdenken, an das man sich erinnert.
Nein, nimm das, was du immer genommen hast und gut ist. Du erinnerst dich nicht mehr dran, weil du ein Vollidiot bist. Man überschätzt sich masslos. Innerhalb von drei Wochen Alltag weiß man nicht mehr, was damals war in dem Situation. Ich schreibe immer noch 2021 nach einem Monat, so als ob ich jetzt in der Lage wäre, ein neues Passwort mit drei Sonderzeichen und irgendwelchen Gags aus dem Podcast-UFO irgendwie zu verbinden, kriegt doch nicht hin. Schaffe ich doch nicht. Bleibt bei euren Leisten. Auch wenn die im Radio immer sagen, die Top sechs Passwörter waren wieder, Passwort, eins, zwei, drei, vier, fünf, sechs, eins, zwei, drei, vier, fünf, sechs, und lustigerweise war Basteln, Basteln war auf Platz vier oder so. Basteln? Basteln. Dann dachte ich kurz, okay, vielleicht soll ich sterben jetzt, weil ich habe den Anschluss verloren. Ich bin wie so ein alter Mann, der nicht mehr weiß, was auf der Welt vor sich geht und der jetzt einfach, it's my turn now, weil Basteln, dann dachte ich mir, okay, jetzt habe ich den Anschluss verloren. Jetzt weiss ich nicht mehr, wo sind alle, hallo, ist denn noch irgendwas, worum geht es, was ist das Leben? Das war, glaube ich, auch unter den Top drei beliebtesten Pornokategorien, war auch Basteln. So, ja. Und jetzt, irgendwas verpassen wir gerade. Ja. Irgendwas sehen wir nicht, was alle anderen sehen. Basteln. Wie Basteln? Vielleicht, wenn man sich am Schreibtisch umguckt und dann die erste Assoziation ist, basteln. Wer bastelt denn? Basteln Kinder basteln? Irgendwas verstehen wir hier. Irgendwas verstehen wir hier nicht. Irgendwas checken wir hier nicht. Weil die schauen sich um und die Kinder basteln gerade. Basteln Kinder noch viele? Entsteht da noch viel? Was ist denn die Definition von Basteln? Mindestens eine Schere und einen... Ja, einen Britstift, halt Rumgeschmatze und Rumgeklebe. Dieser Britt, dieser beissende Brittgeruch. Ja. Papier. Oder für fortgeschritten ein Uhu. Und wahrscheinlich Kinder schreien, weil man sich den Finger geschnitten hat. Ja, genau das ist es. Basteln. Obwohl ich ganz gerne gebastelt habe eigentlich. Also ich habe mit Kindern gearbeitet und ich habe immer ganz gerne gebastelt. Ich habe dann immer so lustige Brillen gebaut, so Brillen ausgeschnitten aus Karton und die dann so verziert, so mit so Federn oder so. Und dann konnten die Kinder sich die dummen Brillen aufsetzen und ich hatte auch so eine dumme Brille auf und dann konnte jeder seine Brille machen. Ich habe einen Laptop gebastelt früher, bis Wasser drüber lief und der lustigerweise auch kaputt ging. Er hat pritzig gelöst halt einfach, das ist die grösste Schwachstelle. Ich habe so einen Laptop gebastelt, wo ich eine Tastatur gemacht habe, konnte man aufklappen und zuklappen und dann habe ich mich immer neben meine Eltern gesetzt und auch so geschäftig getan. In Wahrheit habe ich nichts zu tun gehabt. In Wahrheit habe ich Angry Birds auf meinem Laptop. Du hast nicht mal die E-Mails von deinem Teddybär gelesen? Nein. Einfach auf unbeantwortet ewig zu erbrochen. Ja, aber markiert als wichtig markiert. Also rot mit einem Schoden. Das ist das Todesurteil von jedem Mail, einfach als wichtig. Markieren. Markieren ist... Man weiß aber nicht genau, wo der es dann landet. Ich habe keinen Markiert-Ordner oder sowas. Die haben dann so eine Fahne, aber sind ja trotzdem, müsste ich ja drei Minuten lang scrollen, bis ich wieder bei der Mail bin. Ja, das ist wie mit meinen Briefen. Ich kriege eine Menge Briefe von irgendwelchen Leuten und, ähm, Amt und so. Und, ähm, und, ähm, vielen Dank für Ihr Brief, Amt. Ja, und dann, äh, hab ich einen Briefstapel, den ich nicht lese, aber ich hab noch mal einen Liesti-Briefstapel, also ich leg das dann noch mal auf den Schreibtisch auf einen separaten Stapel, wo die wichtigsten Briefe, wo dann wirklich Finanzamtbriefe und sowas, wo ich mir denke, das sieht wichtig aus, leg das dahin. Die werden genauso nicht gelesen, aber sie sind auf einem separaten Stapel. Mittlerweile ist es so weit, dass ich von diesem Stapel noch einen weiteren dringend Stapel mache, dass ich von diesen zehn Briefen, die da liegen, wirklich nochmal zwei rausnehme und sage, die musst du wirklich unbedingt lesen. Meinen die auch nicht, aber es gibt jetzt drei Stufen der Dringlichkeit, die alle gleichermaßen ignoriert werden. Aber ich denke immer so, nee, du hast die jetzt schon auf dem Schirm, du hast die in petto, du hast die jetzt parat. Also das ist schon mal besser, aber gelesen werden sie nicht. Wir sind exakt im Gegenteil, was das angeht, weil ich die häufig, wenn ich unten am Briefkasten, wenn ich den Briefkasten aufmache, da ist ein Brief drin, den häufig schon aufmache, während ich die Treppe hochgehe. Weil ich das so interessant finde, wenn ein wichtiger Brief kommt, dass ich den sofort aufreiße und wissen will und dann meistens sogar sofort beantworte, wenn das was ist. Wahnsinn, du bist da etwas weiter. Ich will das weghaben, ich kann das nicht haben, diese offene Tasche. Ich will es auch weghaben, aber ich will nichts machen dafür. 19 offene Tabs im Kopf zu haben, finde ich das Schrecklichste. Weg mit den Aufgaben. Ich kann mich auch erst entspannen, wenn ich Aufgaben erledigt habe. Ich kann mich jetzt nicht, ich kann nicht in den Brief vom Finanzamt auf den Wichtigordner legen und dann essen oder sowas. Ich kann mich erst entspannen, wenn ich mir lange genug eingeredet habe, dass das Problem noch bis morgen warten kann. Dann kann ich wirklich abschalten, wenn ich mir lange genug gesagt habe, naja, die werden jetzt nicht sofort mit Antworten rechnen und dann kann ich mich... Dafür bin ich glaube ich ein bisschen zu dumm, weil mir nicht in meinem Kopf, wenn man diesen Streit im Kopf führt, nicht genug Argumente dafür ein. Man gewinnt dann, es gewinnt mein Unterbewusstsein, was cleverer ist. Ja. Als mein Bewusstsein. Ja, ist nicht schlecht. Ja, vielleicht sollten wir uns irgendwie zusammentun. Können wir nicht sagen, wir zeugen ein Kind? Mhm. Also einfach mal jetzt sagen, ja klar, genetisch schwierig, aber kann man nicht irgendwie das vermischen und dann jemanden befruchten damit oder so? Ist das nicht möglich? Ja. Und dann einfach so the best of both worlds. Ja, aber das ist halt die Schwierigkeit, ne? Also kann auch
the worst of worst wars rauskommen.
Ja. Und dann will ich mal wissen, was das für
eine Horrorkreatur ist, die dann
da draußen rumläuft und
die alles verschüttet immer und die Rechnung
nicht zahlt. Und du einfach sagst so
ach Mann, hau ab, ey!
Was bist du denn, Fein?
Dann hätten wir nämlich eine neurotische Person,
die die Briefe nicht liest, alles verschüttet, keinen Technik-Skills hat, gar keine Disziplin hat, im Knast landet sofort. Nur wenn irgendwann mal der Himbeersirup aus Versehen über den Brief läuft und man durch den Umschlag dann Mahnung durchlesen kann, vielleicht dann, vielleicht wird dann die geöffnet, weil es vielleicht, wir kombinieren sich auch diese schlechten Eigenschaften aus Gutem. Weiß man ja auch nicht, Minus und Minus ist Plus, was ich besonderlich nicht verstanden habe, aber anscheinend rein von den Zeichen ergibt das total Sinn, dass zwei Minus übereinander ein Plus sind. Perfekt. Ob Pythagoras sich das so gedacht hat, weiß ich nicht. Pythagoras. Achso, Entschuldigung. Aber da habe ich immer mein Mathelehrer angucken und gesagt, aber es ist wirklich, wie das mal mit. Wirklich, wirklich, wirklich, also sie stellen sich da vorne hin. Ich glaube ihnen das jetzt, aber. Und sie setzen sich da irgendwie jetzt rückwärts auf den Stuhl, was ich richtig cool finde. Und dann sagen sie mit ihren grossen Augen, erzählen sie mir jetzt hier irgendwie mit dem dicken Zeigestock. Und sie haben mit 40 offensichtlich Gel in den Haaren, und ich respektiere das, aber wirklich! Und sie scheinen das zu wissen, ich meine, ihre Schuhe sagen, schreien, Mathelehrer. Ja. Und sie sagen mir jetzt hier in ihrer Jack-Wolfs-Gkin-Jacke, die sie anlassen, aus unerfindlichen Gründen, dass Minus mal Minus Plus ist. Okay, alles klar. Aber, Zwinker, Zwinker, hab ich verstanden. Aber in der Klausur würde ich dann trotzdem meinen Weg gehen, okay, okay, haben wir uns verstanden? Sechs. Ja. Naja, vielleicht wirst du Mathe revolutionieren, wenn irgendwann jemand rauskommt. Nee, stimmt nicht. Das wäre ja auch geil, dass jemand einen Satz des Pythagoras widerlegt und sagt, nee, das war immer Bullshit. Das ist leicht falsch. Es ist halt nah dran, deswegen ist es nicht aufgefallen, dass der Satz des Pythagoras völliger Nonsens ist. Das ist ja meine Hoffnung bei Aliens, dass Aliens kommen und sich, und dann geht man mit denen irgendwie mal, mach mal so ein Abgleich, mach mal so ein Update. Wo sind wir so, was hat die für, und dann sagt man so, ja hier Satz des Pythagoras, wir hatten A² plus P² gleich C². Moment, wir gucken nach. Die so, und man hat sehr viel, davor war ein stundenlanges Meeting,
wo immer gesagt wurde, ja, haben wir auch, haben wir auch, genau, ja,
Licht ist so und so schnell und dann
kommt das als Pythagoras, ja, wir haben hier a² plus b² gleich c².
Was habt ihr da? Ja, wir gucken ganz kurz nach,
wir haben hier a² plus b² durch zwei ist gleich c².
Ähm,
nee, da muss ein Fehl...
Ah, ich sehe gerade,
ah, wir haben Vorzeichen vergessen, ah, wir haben einen Übertrag von Vorzeichen vergessen. Vielleicht sind wir auch falsch. Ah, nee, ich seh schon den Fehler. Ein ganz dummer, dusseliger Fehler hat sich da eingeschlichen. Ach so, nee, hier, guck mal. Ah, ja, na klar. Sorry, wir haben einfach hier ... Nee, kommt vor. Ganz lustig, unsere ganze Mathematik beruht auf diesem ... Ah, scheiße. Und dann kommt raus, der einzige Grund, warum wir noch nicht durchs Weltall schwirren, mit unseren fixen Hyperspace-Motoren, liegt daran, weil wir irgendwie so irgendwo so einen dummen Fehler hatten. Und ich hab hier Minus mal Minus ist Minus. Ja, ja, gut, ne, also ... Das schreibe ich jetzt auch mal bei uns auf, aber, ne, Zwinker, Zwinker. Nee, nee, also. Nee, ich weiß, ihr habt das drauf, ihr kommt ihr mit euren lustigen Anzügen an und euren hochtechnisierten Motoren. Das sind unsere Haut, okay, das sind keine Anzüge. Aber, ähm, nee, das ist ja jetzt. Gut. Nee, ich glaube, wir haben irgendwo so einen dummen Fehler gemacht. Das ist meine These. Und der erfolgreichste Jackson ist Janet Jackson bei uns. Ja, da ist uns ein Riesenfehler unterlaufen, tatsächlich. Wir haben ... Es gab viele Red Flags, aber wir haben ... Auch nach Neverland Ranch haben wir noch gesagt, nee ... Es läuft immer noch ... Die meisten Songs, die im Radio von einem Jackson laufen, ist immer noch Michael. Ach so. Wir haben hier was anderes. Ja, ja. Und das zu Recht. Ihr habt zu Recht was anderes stehen. Ähm ... Nee, wir sind immer noch ... Team Michael. Okay. Vielleicht liegen wir auch falsch. Nee, ich glaub, ihr seht da richtig. Okay. Ich glaub, ihr habt da ... Nee, also wie gesagt, wir sind da total ergebnisoffen, wir können da uns echt nochmal in so ein Premium. Nee, ihr habt das komplett, glaubt mir, das habt ihr richtig. Alles klar. Diese Minus mal Minus Plus Sache weiß ich nicht, aber Michael an zweiter Stelle ist richtig. Okay, gut. Alles klar. Wenn ihr uns jetzt auslöschen wollt, von der Hand verstehe ich's. Ja.
Ja, wollen wir?
Ja? Was ist das für ein Zeichen? Was heißt das?
Was heißt das mit der Hand an deinem Tentakel? Was ist das? Die Tentakel am Hals.
Was ist das für ein Zeichen?
Sag doch, was ist das? Was bedeutet das Zeichen?
Ja, umrücken. Umrücken, ach so. Ja ja dann. Ja, ich verstehe es. Wegen Michael jetzt. Bip, bip, bip, bip, bip. Ja. Das ist, auf das Geräusch habt ihr euch geeinigt, bei den hochentwickelten Waffen. Ja, wir haben uns überlegt, vielleicht wird weniger Krieg geführt, wenn die Waffen nicht so cool klingen. Wenn wir einfach einmal alle sagen, Alter, hör auf mit dem Scheiss, hör auf zu schiess, verdammt nochmal.
Bip, bip, bip, bip, bip, bip, bip, bip, bip, bip, bip, bip, bip, bip, bip, bip, bip, bip, bip, bip, bip, bip, bip, bip, bip, bip, bip, bip, bip, bip, bip, bip, bip, bip, bip, bip, bip, bip, bip, bip, bip, bip, bip, bip, bip, bip, bip, bip, bip, bip, bip, bip, bip, bip, bip, bip, bip, bip, bip, bip, bip, bip, bip, bip, bip, bip, bip, bip, bip, bip, bip, bip, bip, bip, bip, bip, bip, bip, bip, bip, bip, bip, bip, bip, bip, bip, bip, bip, bip, bip, bip, bip, bip, bip, bip, bip, bip, bip, bip, bip, bip, bip, bip, bip, bip, bip, bip, bip, bip, bip, bip, bip, bip, bip, bip, bip, bip, bip, bip, bip, bip, bip, bip, bip, bip, bip, bip, bip, bip, bip, bip, bip, bip, bip, bip, bip, bip, bip, bip, bip, bip, bip, bip, bip, bip, bip, bip, bip, bip, bip, bip, bip, bip, bip, bip, bip, bip, bip, bip, bip, bip, bip, bip, bip, bip, bip, bip, bip, bip, bip, bip, bip, bip, bip, bip, bip, bip, bip, bip, bip, bip, bip, bip, bip, bip, bip, bip, bip, bip, bip, bip, bip, bip, bip, bip, bip, bip, bip, bip, bip, bip, bip, bip, bip, bip, bip, bip, bip, bip, bip, bip, bip, bip, bip, bip, bip, bip, bip, bip, bip, Ja, das ist weg, Mensch! Ja, ich merke es selbst, ich hoffe.
Mein Gott, dann nehmt doch die Insel, ey, scheiss doch auf die Insel.
Insel.
Ja, kämpfen wir nicht immer, geht es nicht immer, geht es nicht immer, es geht doch immer um eine Insel.
Falkland Islands.
Ferroir.
Ferroir Süd.
Am Ende jeder Krieg, sorry, dass ich jetzt mal die Illusionen einfach wegpuste, jeder Krieg geht doch am Ende nur darum, wer kriegt die fucking Insel. Und am Ende kriegt es England. Ich meine, am Ende kriegt es England und es ist ja auch der Grund, warum Island das kriegstreiberigste Volk der Erde ist, die Isländer. Ist ja kein Geheimnis. Madagaskar auch umstritten. Ja, wer kriegt sie? Wer nicht alles um Madagaskar kämpft. Warum gehörten Norwegen grosse Teile der Antarktis? Ich glaube, die waren da als erstes. Haben gesagt, ist hier schon jemand? Nö. Aber die sind sehr weit weg davon. Naja. Na komm. Naja. Man könnte kaum weiter weg sein als Land. Moment, aber ist nicht diese Globusnummer auch, dass gegen oben wird alles enger oder so? Ist oben ein Loch, dass sie unten wieder rauskommen, weil sonst verstehe ich nicht, warum Norwegen sehr viele Teile an der Arktis gehören. Aber das ist doch irgendwie so ein Ding mit irgendwie die Karte, wie wir sie kennen, ist völlig falsch. Ja, aber trotzdem ist Norwegen ganz oben, auch auf der Karte mit den berichtigten Maßstäben ist Norwegen ja ganz oben. Ja, aber die Erde ist ja eine Kugel. Ja. Wenn du nach oben hinten gehst, kommst du ja unten. Ja, ich glaube, auf allen berichtigten Karten ist Norwegen trotzdem mit am weitesten weg von der Antarktis. Wenn ich jetzt nicht einen groben Denkfehler habe. Wer sagt denn, dass ein Land immer zusammenhängen muss? Was ist denn das für eine uralte, antike Überzeugung, dass du nicht einfach sagst, uns gehört das und das. Halt wie so ein, hier, ähm, wie so ein Diablo.
Diabolo.
Du hast halt so zwei Stöcke und in der Mitte eine Schnur.
Ah, und die Stöcke gehören auch mit zur Form.
Die Stöcke sind auch, die Stür ist auch die Form.
Ja.
Ach so, ich dachte, die Erde wäre das Diablo.
Das Land hat zwei Teile, die halt so durch so einen dünnen Korridor verbunden werden.
Okay, ja. Weil ich dachte, Diabolo-förmig würde dann nur das, was man in Luft schmeißt, beinhalten. Aber du meinst auch schon, gehört ein Mensch, der die Diablo-Stecke mit. Nein, guck mal bei den Turtles. Es gibt Leonardo, der hat ein Schwert. Wunderbar. Aber dann gibt es Raffaello, der hat zwei kleine Schwerte. Der hat zwei kleine Kugeln, die er isst. Die jetzt erst mal nicht zusammenhängen, die aber trotzdem eine Einheit sind. Dann gibt es Rocher. Genau, Rocher macht es nochmal ganz anders, wo du ganz viele kleine Krümelchen, diese Kokosstücke auf dem Tisch hast und einen Rest auf dem T-Shirt. Das ist nochmal was ganz anderes. Übrigens. Aber es ist beides Waffen, nur um das zu beenden. Du hast einmal das Schwert. I hast einmal das Raffaello, die zwei kleinen Messer, die ja teilweise während der Kampfmanöver weit voneinander entfernt sein können, aber es ist trotzdem eine Einheit. Und so ist Norwegen eben auch. Du hast ein Messer oben, ein Messer unten. Du meinst, wir sollten alle in grosser Angst leben, dass Norwegen uns irgendwann von beiden Seiten angreift. Von beiden Seiten auffrisst. Ja.
Das ist diese Expansion von beiden Seiten gleichzeitig.
Glaubst du, dass Norwegen unterstützt?
Ja, ich glaube, was sind da unter dem Eise.
Weil da könnten ja tatsächlich auch Kreaturen leben.
Weil es gibt ja manche Kreaturen, die kann man einfrieren.
Und dann, wenn die auftauen, leben die einfach wieder.
Und wer weiß denn, ob nicht im ewigen Eis einfach noch irgendwelche krassen Tiere unter dem Eise leben. Ballrocks. Ballrocks zum Beispiel oder irgendwelche Wale zum Beispiel oder Delfinen. Und wenn das auftaut, weil jetzt... Ich habe jetzt weniger Angst vor von Delfinen. Nee, aber jetzt, guck mal, das ist doch jetzt, sag ich mal, der nächste Science-Fiction-Weg, den wir runtergehen müssen mit dem Klimawandel, des Eisschmilz, was kommt da zum Vorschein? Und dass man dann nämlich sagt, okay, wir haben es versucht mit Vulkan und Orkan, das funktioniert alles nicht, die Leute haben da wenig Angst davor, die schauen sich das sogar gerne an. Das wäre immer geil. Im ewigen Eis ist ein Drache aufgewacht. Ja, gut, aber würde das dazu führen, dass die Leute mehr oder weniger gegen Klimawandel kämpfen? Mehr? Einerseits Angst, dass du sagst, der Drache darf nicht erwachen, Drache nicht erwache. Na, ist so cool, du meinst, Drache ist so cool. Eben, die Leute sagen sich, weißt du, wenn die Welt schon untergeht, dann mit Drache. Aber so im Geheim, so im Geheim lassen unsere Nerds dann immer noch im Fernsehen nachts laufen, weißt du, weil aber eigentlich fliegen immer hin und her. Vorne sagen alle so, nee, nee, wir können den Drachen nicht aufwecken, lass mal das ewige Eis lieber ewiges Eis sein. Ja. Und so, aber im Geheimen läuft da immer Licht an. Ja. Bei Frederik, der große Herr der Ringe-Fan ist, ne, die läuft immer Licht. Und der fliegt auch viel. Der einfach schön grillt den ganzen Tag, immer viel Kohle verbrennt bei sich im Garten. Muss er in Bali Urlaub machen, auf Bali, muss er um Bali herum Urlaub machen. Du warst einen Tag in Bali, danach bist du nach Thailand geflogen.
Warum hat es dir in Bali nicht gefallen, wem gefällt es dir in Bali nicht?
Warum hast du das Smokeshirt schon wieder an, Frederik?
Kann es sein, jetzt warte mal, kann es sein, dass du willst, dass der Drache erwache?
Dass der Drache mit dem coolen Namen, dass der Norwegen... Sormogoth! Sormogoth erwacht? Ne, Frederik? Nein! Da fragen wir jetzt explizit dich! Nein! Okay, also... Bin halt gern Nachmittag in Bali! Also für unseren Don't Look Up-artigen Klimaerwärmungs-Analogie-Film sollten wir vielleicht ein uncooleres Tier nehmen, damit die Gefahr grösser ist. Richtig? Ja, es muss bedrohlich, aber gleichzeitig uncool sein. Ja, forget it. Keine Chance. Keine gibt's nicht. Naja, es gibt schon unbeliebtere Fabelwesen. Basilisk zum Beispiel. Ja, aber scheiß, auf der, ich will auch sehen, wie der Basilisk in Norwegen angreift. Ich will einen Krieg sehen, Norwegen gegen den Drachen,
gegen den ewigen Eisdrachen.
Ja, Drachen,
was ist das langweiligste Fan des Tieres?
Amazing.
Oder einfach so ein grosses Pferd oder so.
Das ist ja lame, meinst du?
Ja, einfach so ein grosses Huhn.
Ja, okay.
Der T-Rex.
Hör auf jetzt, Stefan.
Ich kann mittlerweile nur noch müde drüber lachen. Müde bis leicht aufgeweckt. Aber das fände ich richtig geil jetzt, ehrlich gesagt. Lass mal, was ist noch ... Ja, kann sein, dass da, wenn das Eis abschmilzt, da plötzlich so ein Schnabel, so eine Spitze und du denkst dir, oh nein. Oh, what? Und dann plötzlich wird der Schnabel immer grösser, je mehr Eis abschmilzt, du denkst dir dir, what the fuck, zu welchem riesigen Tier gehört dieser Schnabel? Ja, wo kommt der dazu vor? Lange graue Haare kommen zum Vorschein. Was kann das denn sein? Und alle so. Warte mal, ist das ein Haarband? Was ist das für eine Brille, die in den Haaren gesteckt ist? Was ist das denn? Ist da so eine Halskette an den Brillen dran, dass man sich die umhängen kann? Wer denn, Strohhut, was ist, wozu gehört das denn jetzt hier? Wir taugen mal weiter auf. Ha, T-Rex, fucking T-Rex. Oh nein, oh nein, das muss alles wieder zufrieren. Oh nein, Hilfe, Hilfe. Vor allem dann taut erst der Kopf aus und er so Hallo Leute, hi, hallo Leute, hey, könnt ihr mich hier aufhauen? Kennt ihr schon von NFTs gehört? Oh Gott, weg! Wie ist der Bitcoin-Kurs gerade? Ach, halt den Mund. Ich habe jetzt diese Shitcoins gekauft, warum NFTs? Hier irgendwo muss mein Vapor sein, im Eis, könnt ihr mir den geben? Ich liebe EDM. EDM ist das absolut Coolste und Urlaub auf Bali ist mein Leben. Ja, und ich glaube dann, spätestens dann würde sich die Welt wirklich zusammenschliessen und sagen, auf gar keinen Fall darf dieses Ding auftauen. Ja. Hört auf zu fliegen, hört auf Kohle zu verbrennen, grillen ist nicht mehr.
Grillen?
Ja,
das heißt doch, Kohle ist so schlecht.
Ach so.
Gibt ja andere Grills.
Ja, gut.
Ja, das stimmt. Okay, ja, ja, interessant.
Vielleicht ist das eine Möglichkeit für die Zukunft. Aber das ist ja schon mal gut,
da haben wir jetzt nochmal einen neuen Film kreiert,
Das Monster aus dem Eise. Und... Ist das eh so wichtig? Ja, ich glaube schon. Ich glaube, das sollte ein Comeback machen. Okay. Das sollte ein Comeback machen. Und ja, sehr nah an Don't Look Up, stimmt schon. Die meisten Ideen sind dann doch von Adam McKay. Im Grunde schon. Ja, ist okay. Ist fein. Ist okay. Gut, wir wünschen euch eine schöne Woche weiterhin. Versucht, wenn es geht, Katastrophen zu verhindern, euren Teil zu leisten. Und haltet Aussicht, was die Norweger planen. Ja, haltet da mal ein Auge drauf. Schaut mal, dass sich da ein Freiwilliger meldet. Habt mal ein Auge auf Norwegen. Der sagt, ich halte da mal ein Auge drauf. Nicht, dass sie da irgendwann davonrennen mit ihren verrückten Plänen. Niemand weiß, niemand versteht die Sprache von denen. Nee, niemand versteht das. Es ist unherausfindbar, was sie meinen mit der Hand. Tut uns den Gefallen, bitte. Was soll das bedeuten? Hey. Hey, ja. Sagen die mal zu mir. Hey, ja. Hey, ja. Was soll das heißen? Ich weiß es nicht. Ja. Was ist das für eine Geste, wenn die so mit der Hand reden in der Luft? Mit der Hand schütteln. Was soll das heißen? Was soll das heißen? N weiss es nicht. Was ist das für eine Geste, wenn die so mit der Hand reden in der Luft?
Mit der Hand schütteln, sagen, hey!
Was soll das heißen?
Niemand versteht das.
Nee, komm, hat aber ein Auge drauf.
Ich wünsche euch eine schöne Woche, das war das Podcast-Ufo für diese Woche, nächste Woche gibt es natürlich weitere Ausgaben.
Wir heben ab!
Bis nächste Woche!
It's a voice-by production. Nächste Woche!